RETO MEIER: Colt,
welcome to Whack-a-Pod.
Would you like to try your
hand at taking out a Kubernetes
cluster by whacking each
Kubernetes pod, one at a time?
COLT MCANLIS: Any time I get
to hit stuff with a mallet,
it's a good day.
RETO MEIER: All right,
let's give it a try.
COLT MCANLIS: All right.
RETO MEIER: So we have
that Kubernetes service up.
Every one of these gopher
pods you're hitting
is taking out a Kubernetes pod.
As you can see, the
system is designed
to be extremely resilient.
It's going to continue to
bring these services back up,
while you try and
take them down,
making it very difficult to
actually take them all out.
He's struggling there.
Do you want me to give it a try?
COLT MCANLIS: I can't
get them all down.
RETO MEIER: Let's
see if I can do it.
It wasn't that hard.
I don't know why
you were struggling.
COLT MCANLIS: Cheater.